my 34 years in congress
i've seen the country change
i've seen nevada change the changes in
the country in nevada
have been for the better former nevada
democratic senator harry reid saw a lot
of change in his decades of service but
he'll likely be remembered most as a
fighter a fighter of cancer lost all my
hair it'll come back oh yeah it'll come
back once i get rid of cancer a fighter
of tradition but be vigilant because you
have as much to do with our democracies
any branch of government a fighter in
the ring one of the great fighters of
all time harry mason reed was born in
1939
the son of a minor reed grew up in the
small southern nevada town of
searchlight he started as an attorney in
henderson before being elected to the
nevada assembly in 1968 it was reid's
former boxing coach who chose him to be
his running mate and they won in 1970
then it was a trip to the nevada gaming
commission from 1977 to 1981. whatever
success i had in my educational life my
life as a lawyer my life as a politician
including my time in congress is
directly attributable attributable to
lander my wife then a trip to washington
one lasting more than three decades
first as a congressman then a senator
they want to close government this is
all a subterfuge
nevada's longest serving senator the de
facto head of the democratic caucus
during former president barack obama's
terms he was then senate minority leader
always seeking compromise in his last
speech it was republican senator mitch
mcconnell who introduced him but through
the years
we've come to understand some things
about
one another
and we've endeavored to keep our
disagreements professional
rather than personal reid deciding to
leave washington after suffering serious
eye and facial injuries during an
accident in his henderson home but this
accident
has caused us for the first time to have
a little down time in 2018 the former
senator was diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer by 2020 he said he was in
remission that southern nevada kid
becoming nevada's most powerful in
putting the silver state on the national
map
the gateway to las vegas the airport now
bearing his name the first spot for
millions of tourists visiting the place
harry reid fought for for a lifetime